et pour en parler nous recevons adel bat
kahone directeur du centre de sociologie
de l'irak bonjour et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation on disait il ya
quelques instants la commission des
droits humains fait donc état
d'assassinats ciblés d'enlèvements en
irak qui se cache derrière ces violences
personne personne se cache derrière la
violence c'est la violence de l'êta
maëlys irakiens contre le mouvement de
contestation depuis plusieurs semaines
je conteste cette thèse qui parle de la
main invisible ou de la troisième partie
qui réprime des manifestants
non il n'ya pas la main invisible qu'il
n'y a pas la troisième partie celui qui
réprime officiellement et en plein jour
c'est ce sont des appareils miliciens de
l'état irakien
il faut le dire que cet état irakien a
été fondée à partir de 2003 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui 2020 sur la base miliciens
de ce sont des milices le la colonne
vertébrale de l'état irakien l'ayatollah
ali sistani a donc appelé hier l'état à
protéger les manifestants pacifiques ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'un tel
appel est lancé
est ce que ces interventions la plus
haute autorité religieuse de l'islam
chiite est ce que elle peut changer la
donne en irak et changer le nom mais par
contre il faut bien à ces interventions
peuvent démontrer la discorde au sein de
la famille chiite
aujourd'hui la famille chiite est
traversée par cette grande fracture
entre le mouvement de contestation et
les intimes mouvement de contestation
pas besoin de ça dans lui-même il
faisait partie de son mouvement de
contestation il ya encore deux ou trois
semaines
mais il a pris de la distance pourquoi
parce que lassad est un enfant légitime
de ce régime mis en place depuis 2003 il
faut le dire que ça donne
avant 2003 n'avait pas une histoire
politique ils n'avaient aucune influence
politique ni au sein du régime baassiste
qui dirigeait le pays ni au sein de
l'opposition à ce régime alors lorsque
les américains arrivent et occupe l'irak
à partir de ce moment historique là
l'histoire politique de moktada sadr
quand a commencé
c'est pour dire que son histoire
politique est liée au régime
la disparition du régime probablement
mettra l'avenir politique de saddar en
danger c'est pourquoi il a pris de la
distance avec le
mouvement de contestation est serré et
engagé auprès du pouvoir pour réfréner
le mouvement alors vous vous le dites en
irak est divisée éclaté aujourd'hui mais
pour qu'on comprenne bien quelles rollès
que jouent ces milices ces différentes
ministre qui plonge le pays dans le
chaos et la violence
à ce jour là vous avez 64 organisation
milicienne avec environ 175 mille
combattants
avec un budget de 12 milliards $
consacrés par l'assemblée nationale
irakienne autrement dit les milices ne
sont pas des appareils extra ou para
militaires en irak les milices font
partie intégrante des appareils de
sécurité irakiennes et ils ont adopté
intériorisé inséré dans l'état irakien
je pourrais bien me dire ils sont à
l'intérieur de l'état social et ses
milices qui désigne le gouvernement par
adel abdoul mahdi était a été désigné
par ce drame dès aujourd'hui mohammad
alavi a été désigné hakoum barça des
remous stade à s'adresser à la mairie
c'est pour dire que ces milices là elles
sont à la fois l'eau garant de la
stabilité et la menace sur l'existence
de l'état irakien ce sont des paradoxes
irakien malheureusement depuis quatre
mois les les contestataires ont comme
donc l'espace public pour dénoncer un
pouvoir qu'ils jugent corrompus et
incompétents qu'est ce qu'ils ont obtenu
ce qu'ils ont obtenu des choses jusque
là absolument ils ont obtenu beaucoup de
choses par exemple pour la première fois
de 2003 à 2020 on a un premier ministre
qui a démissionné ça c'est une grande
victoire
la deuxième chose ils ont obtenu la
réforme de la loi électorale c'était une
ligne rouge à ne pas toucher à pour le
gouvernement
troisièmement par exemple la réforme de
la constitution quatrième chose
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que le
gouvernement de transition a promis à
peu près 120 mille emplois le mouvement
a obtenu énormément de victoire mais par
contre ça dépend comment on se place et
on se place
si on s'identifie comme un mouvement
révolutionnaire qui est engagée dans la
lutte finale
on n'a rien obtenu si on s'engage au et
on s'identifie comme un mouvement social
les victoires sont déjà là comment est
ce que vous voyez l'évolution de la
situation dans le pays était prochaine
même ces prochains mois malheureusement
je ne suis pas je ne suis absolument pas
optimiste pourquoi je ne suis pas
optimiste parce que je pense que
aujourd'hui l'état et le mouvement se
retrouve dans une impasse
dans cette impasse la toutes les
conditions objectives sont réunis pour
rentrer dans une guerre civile
merci d'avoir pris le temps de répondre
à nos questions à des laves à kahone
directeur du centre de sociologie d'irak
ces eaux